[Music]
and good day for kids because tesla has
announced an all-electric 1900 cyber
quad for the young ends [ __ ] i hate this
[ __ ] what why because i saw it i went
online it's out of stock how much is it
for this was already trying to get one
for himself before tyga oh honestly i
was gonna buy three of them does it look
like a power wheel
oh it's a power wheel it looks like the
cyber truck but it's a quad but it's for
kids well well the cyber truck already
was making an atv for adults and this is
a mini version of the atv oh so it's
like a power wheel yeah so but it goes
up to like 25 miles an hour for kids
dude that's scary for children
i was trying to buy three of them whoa
get the [ __ ] out of here
if your kid has this it's such a big
flush oh dude he's the coolest kid ever
[Music]
see you got an adult up on there that's
[ __ ] trying to buy three of them dude
you're not gonna get the regular size
one for yourself i live next to millions
of places that look like that but
they're sold out get four so then how
much we could write 1900
[ __ ] really oh wait so this is like the
flame thrower all electric 1 900 cyber
quad
sold out like december that
yeah they quietly launched this uh a
four-wheel atv for kids cyberquad for
kids is available to order but like he
said it's sold out and we'll begin
shipping in two to four weeks the
surprise announcement comes after two
years more than two years after tesla
announced a full-size cyber quad atv to
complement the futuristic cyber so the
full-size one is already out yet or are
they rolling out the kids ones first
kids one just came out first
let me see if i can find the uh
the main one it's sold out yeah i saw it
the day of and the day of i logged in to
try to
get in and it's already sold out yeah
this was when it was uh advertised with
the cyber truck the first time they
brought it out but i think it's sweet
you're gonna have to get a secondary
market i i i enjoy the
visual of bart being on the kids one
though i think that uh it'll look like
donkey kong in the mario kart game oh
dude no imagine you have the tesla
flamethrower as well and you're just
like driving around with boats like
donkey kong
you can buy that in the secondary market
now i think but like not that much more
it's like 1400 ish 8 000.
what secondary market are you getting a
flamethrower or a kid's quad yeah what
do you think ebay i think ebay i could
know i saw on an episode of pawn stars
like someone gave me that
kid
cyber quad see if i can find a secondary
market for it right now no they don't
because they didn't ship it yeah they
haven't that hasn't come out yet but it
comes down to like four to six weeks
look for the flamethrower flamethrower
yeah
not by tesla that's boring company right
yeah eva flame thrower
boring company
[Music]
can you find it shopping shopping okay
you get oh damn okay anywhere from 2200
5000
thousand why conditions look look at the
um complete or sold items and then you
know how much it actually costs oh cause
that's the bidding price yeah
i mean this 2200 one already looks
pretty good for me is there a lot of
bids for that one have you guys held one
no have you have you never
don't even know what it looks like in
real life
i think i saw one in a david dobrik vlog
once i feel like he's got everything
would happen that [ __ ] dude
not a flamethrower is that what it's
called yes
imagine having just having a
flamethrower in your house that's a
pretty crazy thing like imagine someone
breaking in and you're just like
whipping out your flamethrower it's
probably not that effective if they're
in your house huh because i think it's
enough to scare them
yeah that's true once you have a
flamethrower on your hands they better
run the [ __ ] out right it looks like
your curtains on fire yeah something
something's gonna collateral you've
never seen it before it looks like this
guy right here comes in a case that's so
dope damn man that's such a not a
flamethrower
it's pretty good i like them i didn't
know they were available to for
purchasing i just thought it was like
some like weird unique he's pretty
[ __ ] sick when he comes out with
those little things that he drops like
when they came out with the tesla
whiskey or tequila or whatever the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you [ __ ] went
yeah they sold out immediately and then
they were like reselling for like 20
grand or some stupid [ __ ] what's a
household product that you would buy if
it was tesla probably everything dude
toaster air fryer oh i would buy an air
fryer that's cool yeah tesla air force
you know i'll be next level i'll
probably be like solar panels
the toilet i'll be down yeah tesla
[Music]
i do like a thermostat for tesla oh [ __ ]
got like a nest this one's pretty good
though already though i think so i don't
know i feel like somehow tesla is just
going to up it yeah i want to be in like
i want the temperature of hawaii right
now honolulu oh yeah it's going to be
tight it's not even by it's not even by
numbers by places i want to feel there
yeah
do you think that's going to be some
metaverse [ __ ] is like you could have
these tesla temperature controlled homes
and [ __ ] and then you go traveling with
your friends and [ __ ] and then you got
like hawaii temperature and then you're
like oh my god it's so hot i know huh
and then they like have tesla mosquitoes
and [ __ ] they'll come out
it's the whole experience
it's the whole feeling dude tesla
malaria
insects and it's like we all went on a
metaverse vacation together we get back
on metaverse jk news we could talk about
our vacation and how man i thought
hawaii would be way more cooler is so
hot dude and i got bit by mosquitoes and
we could tell our story and [ __ ] oh she
just went to the real one yeah
but then we gotta [ __ ] fly for five
hours that's true yeah
do you realize that
in the not so distant future since elon
is like doing all this stuff i'm gonna
i'm saying elon because now we're
talking about flame throwers and [ __ ]
we're going beyond tesla right yeah but
we got what we got like tesla obviously
which is not just about electric
vehicles it's like about batteries and
solar power and then obviously like
getting into the market with like all
the retail people and stuff right then
we got like [ __ ] uh the boring
company we got uh [ __ ] deep mind
we've got uh neuro link right you guys
familiar with neural link they already
completed the tests on the [ __ ] pigs
with that one so they can [ __ ]
jack you up and be in the matrix they
got starlink so they got internet
satellite internet that's like way
faster than a regular internet available
anywhere in the world literally anywhere
third world country [ __ ] mountains
you can't do that yet right
it's accessible but it's not available
to everybody commercially yet but it is
it's already up and that's why they've
been [ __ ] just constantly launching
spacex has been constantly launching
like hundreds of satellites con like
consistently like throughout the even
this year they [ __ ] put up like
another like 40 or whatever satellites
to complete an entire grid so out in
like the just outer atmosphere of like
our planet they're gonna be able to have
an entire ring grid of like these
satellites that can balance everything
and they're all under one [ __ ]
company all available to the highest
bidder at the end of the day
it is better than inspection though i'm
super down that's why their stocks keep
going up huh yeah but imagine you got
like a worldwide link
plus like
an individual
link
and like they already got like all the
[ __ ] in your home
anything from a flamethrower to a atv to
a car to like a [ __ ] battery
generator that's like powering your
entire house it's gonna be crazy this
was gonna run our entire lives that's
why i support the local native americans
dude
we just just give me a blanket and some
like
clay tents and [ __ ] says the guy who got
pissed that he can buy three of these
things
no i rather have [ __ ] a seesaw wheel
set where we bounce back and forth and
we can go down the road
i'm gonna go away from you know native
americans are looking at bar like shut
up fool we want tesla
he's all talking about the huff and puff
ride as if they [ __ ] made that [ __ ]
up yeah like that's our culture like oh
yeah this is that's what we're doing all
the native americans are going across
[ __ ] america with huff and puffs clay
tents you know all that stuff
[ __ ] adobe homes and [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] atv parked right outside
i bet you their homes are gonna be
looking like star wars where it's like
outside it's all clan adobe but when you
go inside it's all technologically
advanced because that's like new mexico
all their styles they look like it's a
spanish mission and then when you open
the door it's like
[ __ ] nice because they could afford
good real estate
what are those uh clay homes called
adobe adobe
yeah then we have to like bake those as
a [ __ ]
yeah yeah
the red clay
yeah the red clay red clay they put a
couple of strands of grass in there so
it has like some sort of like rigidity
look at you dude
[Music]
what is it called indian bricks i don't
know if that's culturally like right
these days but then like you would get
dry grass
and you would get dry grass and like
straw and then you would get a mold and
then you put mud in there and then you
put the straw that's exactly what you
just said dry
yeah but did you did you do that as a
kid to like uh uh to learn about school
native americans our schools suck dude
we didn't do that that's what made it
fun as [ __ ]
he actually like learned something but
even though they're probably calling it
indian still they used to say you gotta
say indian style you remember that yeah
oh yeah but then now it's cross-legged
just like yeah do they still say fob
squat
squat yeah i think it's okay when you
when you're a fob
only if you're a father you can call
other people fob squatting they say
crisscross applesauce now oh yeah what
does that mean you're such a dad that's
what i don't know
i
facing indian style when we were a kid
but now the teachers go okay cris cross
applesauce and all the kids they cross
their legs
dude sitting indian style that's
someone's gonna some teachers get
canceled for that soon for sure it's
gonna make a comeback someone's gonna be
in there somewhere in the midwest i
think
they probably did invent it of course
wait what what
sitting cross-legged the engines yeah do
you think they're invented
what do you think they invented it yeah
probably probably
i'm with bart on this one that's a
deeper offense
that's true because white people can't
sit on floors they can't do a full spit
on floors bad mobility everything
they can't squat dude
i get surprised i was like what the [ __ ]
you have to learn to do a whole [ __ ]
full body squad that [ __ ] blew my mind
from personal experience when i train
people yeah asian people across the
board i've never met one asian person
i've trained that had bad
like uh mobility even david yeah even as
bad as they were their squat is perfect
can you can you guys all uh i guess bop
squad yeah yeah you know you canceled
but i can't do her you know kimchi
squatter
i can't do it no
wait that's because you're a fish full
okay so i gotta go
okay
oh my goodness are you [ __ ] serious
i'm serious i can't do it i can do it
like this but then it's like really hard
push your knees forward a little bit
more maybe if you put a cigarette in
your mouth yeah oh true
spread your legs hold my hand okay okay
you're going to lean back a little bit
but when you're going down i want you to
push your knees forward go
push your knees forward stay upright
stay upright okay go there you go there
push your knees one more
wow can you stay here no damn we use
this while using tension just like you
could break parallel
if i go like this like you know
controlling but this isn't working out
that's so good you're white dude he is
he does have a new zealand passport yeah
you from your kiwi look at this guy oh
god damn it no your face was turning red
from just resting mike we gotta get you
to hit the squats dude
so the thing is it's really interesting
because it's like um i have a white
friend who lives in china and he can do
it so i feel like it's like this thing
you grow up doing oh it's regional huh
no no no it's it's it's a cultural thing
because it's like because i never saw my
parents doing it my dad i don't think my
dad can do it he sits on chairs all day
yes we ate on the floor
how about you you guys ate on the floor
yeah yeah we i i in the floor too but um
what the how did you
applesauce that's how you eat on the
floor um but mainly i ate on the table
chris it was on the table thinks he's
above us man it's high and mighty
[ __ ] dude your mobility's so bad dude
[Music]
you